depuis là il y a des renforcement
policiers des choses comme ça des
habitants justement
et quand la police ils viennent je suis
pas tout le temps tranquille ce qui est
choquant c'est le thon du règlement qui
circule et en fait on a l'impression que
c'est tellement démocratisé qu'on a
l'impression que c'est devenu un
commerce comme un autre ça parle
d'employé ça parle d'horaire on a
l'impression qu'il parle du travail et
c'est eux qui dicte la loi c'est
complètement hallucinant là où la police
a du mal à malheureusement à se faire
respecter donc c'est vrai que ces
affiches elles sont choquantes vous
voulez que je fasse quoi c'est pour ne
tranquillité qu'on s'inquiète vous dites
là pour le bout de papier qu'en gros qui
a été affiché là là aujourd'hui là je
peux rentrer chez moi me faire contrôler
ou pour rien il y a des renforcements
policiers ce n'est pas vraiment de Deal
dans votre quartier ça n'existe pas
dit qu'il y avait pas dit que j'avais
pas remarqué mais la majorité du temps
la base qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
c'est accidentogène c'est que c'est
dangereux d'y être que vous dites parce
que vous y êtes moi on fait des
barbecues on fait plein de choses